a Sun's video game addiction leave me
alone crosses the line who do you think
you're talking to
video games we all love them some love
them too much you don't love them too
much do you today in Dr Phil Dr Phil vs
gamer boy don't pretend you're better
than this kid I know you've all been
there
all right well let's check it out guess
what he wants by bullying us and
terrorizing this house Nico has threaten
to kill us taking back control Jesus
Christ
that's not gamer rage I don't know what
it is you're not going to school so
you're basically just sleeping wait they
actually got him into the studio that's
impressive that's a
what's this price
I've been doing YouTube wrong I need a
studio people hyping me up when I do a
video yeah I just get a bunch of
comments saying first this sucks I want
this
basically drop out of school
so he has time to play video games 17
hours a day
17.
bro I get tired after like an hour
his mom even has to negotiate with him
to take a shower that's normal for
gamers it's tough out there
really playing into all the stereotypes
here doesn't want to shower
all right he can't be that bad all right
let's check out this kid I asked you
hours ago to clean up that mess
what's going on
damn now seems like a nice
well-developed child Nico can get so
angry he will destroy everything in the
house anything in his path anything that
Nico can get his hands on it's Christ
we'll get destroyed
but he's not destroying the uh
Playstation
I guarantee you that
before we continue quick word from
sponsor nordvpn greatest VPN
that's how passionate I am about nordvpn
y'all know what a VPN is y'all know why
you should use it but let me tell you
what nordvpn is better than all the
other ones they truly care about your
security with amazing features like
threat protection always protecting you
no matter what Bing Bang Boom they're
constantly working on new features to
keeping you safe now introducing dark
web monitor dark web that's a scary
place with one click you're protected
from dark web previously if you sign up
to a website and that website gets
compromised all your information is
leaked and you're likely to not even
know about it but with the dark red
monitor what it does is that nordvpn is
constantly checking this for you now all
you have to do is Click dark web monitor
on and boom Norway API is constantly
scanning for new compromise leaks to see
if you are in Epic danger just click it
on and you don't even have to worry
about it one of many amazing features
with nordvpn you really should be good
you really should you should VPN nordvpn
now VPN truly cares about you more than
your dad does
oh well anyway and right now if you sign
up with the link in the description
nordvpn.com PewDiePie for a two-year
deal you get additional four months for
free it's risk-free with nordvpn's
30-day money-back guarantee
all you have to do is check out the link
in description when you sign up to get
this offer don't just go to nordvpn.com
and sign up and then oh I could have
used PewDiePie's link he would have
gotten me the extra special deal in four
months for free you still ain't you
dummy thank you very much for watching
this video and let's get on with it I
take him off the internet and he
immediately starts throwing things and
breaking things and it's cost us
thousands of dollars replacing
everything that he's broken oh he did
break the control his controller if I
don't give him what he wants I'm gonna
a child has a gaming problem and breaks
his controller just don't get another
control is that this feels like a very
solvable problem eh
you're enabling this child he wants to
be a YouTuber when he gets older
I couldn't Force Nico to get up and go
another Dr Phil child that wants to be a
YouTuber I feel weird about this I hate
that that's the case I've ruined
generations of children's and
aspirations
anything else don't do it run with UK
it's not worth it I want to become a
YouTuber so I can play even more video
games he's a very large child
image of me more now because he knows
that I'm disabled I'm in a wheelchair
and there's not much I can do they'll
strike out and he'll hit me physically
I'm no match for him he's a big kid is
that a fortnight pillow
I was just thinking I wonder where he's
playing that makes him like 17 hours a
day he's definitely playing fortnite
Nico begs and bags and begs to get what
he wants can I please just get 3.99 no I
shouldn't even have to bribe you to take
a shower I should I can't understand him
what
well that is I don't want to know what
he's asking
3.99
once give the man give the man what he
wants it's very simple bang the phone
again and I take it away from you
take your showers I can't you physically
can't it's impossible so in the end I
allowed him to get the small things that
he wanted
um and he's going to take a shower so
you gave him what he wanted and he he
couldn't even he couldn't even take a
shower oh my God
four hours late it's now 3 45 and you
promised me at 2 30 you would take a
shower I forgot well I'm reminding you
is parenting this hard I mean the child
is clearly horrible but I mean you can't
even make him get take a shot
self permission
to speak to your parents in a
disrespectful way well there had to be
some point at which you said you're not
so tough now are you a little gamer boy
mother father or tell my father I'm
going to stab you tonight
Choice it's interesting how as soon as
Dr Phil comes out they're just like the
amount of disrespect for the parents in
their home in front of camera but in a
studio like
you were saying I don't demean her I
don't tell her she's worthless but you
do call her effect
when I get mad I don't think and I it
just comes out would that be a yes yes
okay but you you want to play some
Antics with me that you don't tell her
she's worthless you just tell her she's
a fast message
yeah
she's recording you Dad you better not
hit me she's recording you so apparently
the dad is only home two hours a day
because he works the whole day I mean I
would probably work a little extra if
that's the house I had to come home to
him but and he gets so angry he blacks
out it's really weird
I pass out probably in the beginning
it's so enraged
get off me I guess my body can't handle
it anymore and then I hit the floor
there you go it's super weird it could
range I've been out 30 minutes for 45
minutes are you okay no what
I have no memory of what happens when I
pass out I don't know I don't remember
all right so here we are in the studio
the child made it I think makes you
first time you get I honestly don't know
when you're
screaming at her and yelling moms and
threatening to smash her in the face
with your controller how do you feel
afterwards I feel really bad about it
I'm not buying it not buying it let's
take a look at this game of race
[Music]
leave me alone Nico leave
I'm like too cringe for me I don't know
did you give yourself permission to
speak to your parents in a disrespectful
way
[Music]
that's fine man okay
Nico has charged over four thousand
dollars on her credit card for gaming
tokens she says and face zero
consequences
uh I'm wondering why we'll talk about
that when we come back yeah what the
hell
they're very solvable problems that
reminds me of that one clip or Dr Phil
it makes like a promo for a video game
if you're looking for something to do
that's fun relaxing and good for your
brain and from my brain way for you to
take a much needed break and it's right
on your phone for free
thank you Dr Phil for the promo
the artwork is amazing all of the
challenges and levels are super fun and
I really like all the super cute animals
that play along with you me too yeah
they do we have really cute super cute
animals in pewdiepie simulator all right
so get ready
set
all right play
it's not only enjoyable but it's
challenging and it can sharpen your
brain you're also getting double the fun
playing Solitaire and can actually build
a farm and harvest it as you progress
into game you win different Awards
incredible this game has different
surprises as you progress so it's
challenging and fun my marriage is
falling apart my children hate me and
I'm about to lose my job at all those
worries goes away the moment I stop
listening to my wife kids and buses
start playing Solitaire heart
PewDiePie tuber simulator so if you're
looking for a mini assistant oh yeah
they're having fun look at him
take a break for your busy day and try
growing some cool crops cool so how are
you doing I finished I won oh you did
all right
congratulations to both of you God it
looks like it's killing him inside to do
this you know how many promo requests
I've gotten like these like this the
most garbage mobile game ever and you
just they're just throwing a ton of
money on you and I'm like how am I gonna
promote this there's just no way I can
pretend this game was even fun but uh Dr
Phil pulled it up she loved the graphics
because it's really animated and fun
and uh both of you are really good at
the game and that makes you it's okay
anyway what would have to happen for
there to be peace in your house from
your standpoint
um
probably just letting me play my video
games whenever I want oh yeah that
that'll fix the problem yes right you
played 17 hours a day your problem is
playing More by fixing it by playing
More in Jesus Christ dude I love the
mother complains about our son being
entitled and disrespectful and then tell
us that that just stop punishing the
sums for his action well it looks like
this the guy is actually physically uh
gonna hit him I don't know Sweden that's
illegal you can't just uh there's got to
be a better way man
I love how he thinks that's gonna fix it
yeah yeah so you wouldn't be expected to
do any chores you wouldn't be expected
to go to school and get an education
you just want to be rolled up in a
blanket playing a video game no I'm not
just playing what I would do school yeah
and stuff sure
you're not doing that though right no
you're not are you crying now stinks
stink gamer go take a shower I do have a
plan and the plan right multi-sided
and multi-layered and I think you are
going to be shocked at what I think
needs to happen here he needs to
download solitary grain Harvest it's a
fun relaxing game with cute animals that
is good for your brain
uh it'd be so funny if I took their
sponsorship and I got paid to promote my
god oh that would have been so good
to be here in the audience today and
that's Shane Gallagher
sharing is the executive director of
Windgate Wilderness therapy so the ranch
oh absolutely you could say that Nico
needs a device detox so he will
absolutely be detoxed not just from he
won't have access to electronics but the
Mind patterns are going to be changed
because he's going to be in a natural
environment so circadian rhythms all of
these things that cicading rhythms
excuse me what what is his therapy I
mean I agree he probably needs a detox
that's for sure
[Music]
wait what he passed out it happened
again oh my God he gets either enraged
or stressed and goes unconscious are you
here oh my God
get out of it
actually spoke in The Green Room
has given us an amazing gift we could
never hope to achieve you're gonna be
going to this facility where you're
gonna have an amazing time you just
don't know it yet is that cool can I
bring my Xbox
are you gonna be out in nature wait
don't go away You're Gonna Go with me
have you been paying attention
you're going to get off your devices and
stop relying on that it's not enjoying
life again all right you seem open to it
I love you so much and I'm gonna talk to
you soon all right they're nice to each
other now cool maybe this hasn't
happened ending after a while bye buddy
needs it
wait after only nine days nigga's
friends no
no
you were hopeless
why why
[Laughter]
is cool yeah it's not gonna kill you oh
my God
I guess I mean I guess you get weak as a
parent not me strong Ah that's
unbelievable so nothing get resolved
here today hope you guys enjoyed that I
think a lot of people struggle with this
when like kids playing games and they
don't know how to how to deal with that
I think there's a lot of kids like that
especially once you become YouTubers or
I want to become a professional gamer so
therefore I have to play video games all
day I swear I need to 17. clearly the
child is not happy either even though he
gets exactly what he wants he's just
stay home play video games you'd think
you know he'd be at least respectful to
his parents or do the minimal if I was
in school right and my parents said hey
you don't have to go to school but like
you have to like take a shower once a
day I'd be like
you're asking for too much like I can't
do that this is ridiculous I can relate
a little bit because like my parents did
not want me to play video games at all
because they thought it was like making
me not social or um yeah I don't know I
guess they didn't like it but I guess
what they didn't understand is like all
my friends in class we were playing
games together online I just think
parents maybe don't realize like how
kids can interact with it I think just
limiting it it's the way to go just like
if you do this you get to play this
amount of time and then there's no
leverage on that on that time you can
spend it as you want but once that
time's up it's up there's more to life
than just one thing all right video
games is not that important uh you
realize that when you get older but you
can teach a child that when they're
younger you know doesn't mean they can't
do it at all right I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did you know
what to do don't forget to check out the
foreign